to say that someone has daddy issues is
a somewhat rude and humiliating way of
alluding to a very understandable
longing for a father who is strong and
wise who is judicious kind perhaps at
point stuff but always fair and
ultimately always on our side
it would be so understandable if we were
to feel we wanted someone like this in
our lives especially at moments of
confusion chaos the longing for a strong
father has been a recurring theme
throughout history most religions have
conceived of their central divinities as
male parents in ancient Greece Zeus was
described as the father of men and gods
in Christianity God was the Heavenly
Father in Germanic mythology Odin was
the all-father the father of all other
gods the longing has been no less
present in secular culture in the u.s.
the individuals who led the war of
independence and drew up the
Constitution came to be known as the
founding fathers Garibaldi that
dignified and authoritative man who
fought for the unification of Italy in
the 19th century earned himself the
title of the father of the fatherland in
early childhood we are all immensely
weak and in need of protection we can't
understand the world
we're so fragile we could be killed by a
moderately sized dog so much feels
mysterious and outside of our control a
hunger for a daddy is in the
circumstances wholly natural a grown man
inevitably and rightly seems immensely
impressive to a small child they appear
to know everything the capital of New
Zealand how to drive a car how to say a
few words in a foreign language how to
peel the avocado they go to bed
mysteriously late they're up before you
in a swimming pool you can put your arms
around their neck and rest on their back
they once kicked a football so high
you nearly couldn't see it it's beyond
astonishing when one is for the paradox
of daddy issues is that those who have
them are almost always people who didn't
have very good fathers when they were
small
perhaps one's father was
but ultimately cruel bullying or
disinterested perhaps he was more
concerned with another sibling or with
his work perhaps he wasn't around much
left the house after a divorce or died
young the adult longing for a father is
not the result of having had a good
father in childhood it's a consequence
of abandonment
the longing can incline us to some
tricky patterns of behavior however
mature and skeptical we may be in most
areas in relation to the idea of male
protection we remain a little like the
young child we once were and haven't
been allowed to mature away from we
secretly yearn for a man to step in and
fulfill an unquenched fantasy role
they'll take charge they'll make the big
decisions they'll be tough and certain
to make our problems go away they'll
make sure the money side of things is
sorted they'll get angry and aggressive
with anyone who hurts us they'll be
proud of us and love us as we are we'll
be looking out for daddies and
friendships at work and not least in
politics the danger is that these
daddies may in the end hugely damage our
trust for it isn't in anyone's power to
us wage the sort of longings we bring to
bear on them they may know very well
what we want and naively or cynically
promised to provide it for us but
gradually too late we stand to realize
that they had a thousand flaws as we all
do we may realize that they're bullying
rather than noble that our enemies
haven't gone away that they couldn't
help us but there isn't in fact enough
money in the world to do what they
promised and that in fact they didn't
really love us at all the fantasy daddy
figure of adulthood isn't in fact a good
father for one big reason truly good
humans no they aren't that powerful and
are happy to admit to the fact cleanly
and honestly just as soon as we're ready
to take the news which is normally when
we're around 12 years old and conscious
of new powers and capacities a good
father doesn't beyond that age pretend
to be all-powerful they confess they
can't solve all our problems and can't
magically save us from a myriad of
dangers no matter how much
I wish they could the good daddy
disappoints us just as soon as we're
strong enough to bear reality out of
love they deflate the idea that there
could ever be a perfect ideal daddy they
try as best they can to help us grow up
if we encounter someone who has daddy
issues the temptation is to get
frustrated to tell them to mature to
mock them and in particular to poke fun
at the particular daddy figure they
might have identified this isn't either
a very wise or ultimately a very kind
strategy it simply tends to entrench
their devotion because whenever we're
attacked we of course feel ever more
intensity than ever the need for the
protection of an idealized father what
we really need to help us out of our
daddy issues is something more like the
actions of a genuinely good father
someone who acknowledges our suffering
and our fears who deeply wants what's
best for us and isn't reluctant to say
so but who at the same time out of love
wants to help us to come to terms with a
messy and essentially disappointing
world a man who out of love would
encourage us to be independent and
specifically not to fantasize that
anyone however outwardly imposing can
ever do the impossible
good daddies allow us to bear the truth
that there are in the end no daddies we
love bringing you these films if you
want to help us to keep bringing you
thoughtful content please consider
supporting us by visiting our shop at
the link on your screen now
you